[Music]
we probably all agree that Maddie
Ziegler is nothing like she used to be
she went from being a bratty and
dramatic reality TV show star to
becoming well you'll see if there's one
thing we know for sure is that Maddie's
transformation is downright spectacular
but would you really expect anything
else from Abby's favorite student yeah
we didn't think so it's about the kids
and about them shining onstage and not
them becoming stars Maddie Ziegler was
groomed for stardom at a very young age
she began mastering her footwork at the
Abby Lee dance company when she was only
two years old Maddie's a natural and
she's super dedicated to her craft
making her the perfect student in Abby
Lee Miller's eyes Maddie may have been
at the top of the pyramid more often
than anyone else but that never stopped
her from shedding tears and causing
scenes during her time on Dance Moms
Maddie quickly became known for being a
dramatic student who had exceptionally
high expectations of herself being
compared to her friends and intensely
scrutinized by every mom on the show
didn't do much for Maddie's personality
but her committed ways natural-born
talent and passion turned her into a
big-time star in no time and guys this
is just the tip of the iceberg nothing
kick starts a career like the
endorsement of a renowned celebrity and
in a way this is exactly what happened
to Maddie in 2014 SIA contacted Maddie
via Twitter asking if she wanted to play
her in the video for her first single
SIA was a fan of Dance Moms and quickly
fell in love with Maddie's facial
expressions and stellar dancing
abilities she first appeared in the
music video for chandelier and as Sia's
fame grew and grew so did Maddie's SIA
and Maddie have been inseparable ever
since
Maddie continuously plays her in her
music videos and even dances for her
during stage performances they have a
super close relationship why else would
see you buy Maddie a brand new car for
her 16th birthday
SIA and Abby Lee Miller might have
turned Maddie into a star but in reality
her star quality speaks for itself
before long everyone wanted to meet the
girl who was dancing her way through
Hollywood Maddie appeared on Dance Moms
from 2011 to 2016 during this time she
also danced on the view and made
appearances on Entertainment Tonight and
Good Morning America but her career
really kick-started when she chose to
leave Dance Moms behind and explore new
horizons she went on to become a guest
judge on So You Think You Can Dance in
2016 and dance for the audience's of the
Ellen DeGeneres Show she's appeared on
so many talk shows TV series and movies
that it's hard to keep track but being a
socialite and talented performer aren't
the only thing she's got in the bag
turns out she's a business person too
and an aspiring actress as well how else
would she get on Steven Spielberg's
radar you know you've made it when you
publish a memoir at only 14 years old
the Maddie Diaries quickly became a New
York Times bestseller her fans jumped at
the chance to get the inside scoop on
what really happened during her time on
Dance Moms despite her young age Maddie
had a lot to say about her upbringing
which was jam-packed with rehearsals
dance competitions and public
appearances during an interview with
build series Maddie opened up about why
she chose to write a memoir according to
the star she felt as though a lot of
people thought they knew everything
about her when in reality that was far
from the truth the Maddie Diaries gives
fans the inside scoop and also shows
them that despite all the fame and
glamour Maddie's a normal teenage girl
just when we thought that Maddie
couldn't get any bigger she turns around
and partners up with Kate Hudson is the
most incredible actor and she's probably
as my biggest inspiration in life in
2019 Maddie and Kate announced that they
had teamed up to work on a
limited-edition collection for fabletics
this size inclusive brand was co-founded
by Kate Hudson in 2013 and many
celebrities have gone on to reparative
wear since Maddie knows a thing or two
about active wear and its importance
we're not surprised that she caught
Kate's attention it's hard to believe
that Maddie was born in 2002 after all
she's accomplished more in 16 years and
many of us will in a lifetime maddie is
a role model through and through and
she's always keeping the
with brands new projects like
collaborating with pop-tarts on top of
pardoning with fabletics Mady is also
collaborating with pop-tarts the young
star is promoting contests and
encouraging her fans to send in pop-tart
dance videos for the chance to win cool
merchandise Maddy has come a long way
from being the emotional and sometimes
bratty kid from Dance Moms and she's not
done yet Maddie's a dancer a reality TV
star a published author a model a brands
promoter and a makeup enthusiast and now
it looks like Maddie wants to add
acclaimed actress to her title Maddie
acted in the past she's made small
appearances on shows like Pretty Little
Liars Nicky Ricky Dicky and Dawn and
Austin and Ally
but now it looks like this teenage
celebrity is ready to take on more
serious projects in 2017 Maddie starred
as Christina in the book of Henry and
now she's been cast as Jack in West Side
Story West Side Story will be released
sometime in 2020 and it's directed by
none other than Steven Spielberg being
cast into one of Spielberg's movies is
no small feat which is why millions of
people are eager to see Maddie in action
she'll be starring alongside and sell
Elgort and Rita Moreno this musical
centers around forbidden love and will
definitely be a tearjerker
Mandy has gone from being a timid
dramatic and at times a bratty kid to a
professional inspirational and highly
successful young woman she's transformed
before our very eyes
and continues to inspire her fans every
single day are you guys excited to see
Maddie's performance in West Side Story
let us know in the comment section below
give this video a big thumbs up if you
love the Zeigler sisters and don't
forget to subscribe to the things for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]